Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now we're gonna go down in the ocean..
We're gonna go deep, we're gonna go WAY down there.
And uh, we're gonna try to find
the b-b-bagausi, the bangoosie, the
boon-boon-shadi
The baibobo, the *Other playful rambling*
Whatever they call it, I cant even,
Why can't I never remember that name? I'm the worst with names-
But either way we're gonna go down there, we're gonna find-
this place, and we're gonna find their information about what is down deep in the Inactive Lava Zone
and maybe find some cool stuff on the way so let's get to it.
"Hear Ye hear ye denizens of the deep,
Markimoo is coming the fuck down!"
Oh boy that don't look good...
Haaaam-boink!
Hello! Anybody home? Anybody?
Anybody home? Anybody want to tussle with the muscle?!
Huh?! No?
Alright then, you probably chose wisely...
Okay, where am I? Where am I exactly?
Ooo, okay, I might've found the entrance to the Lava Zone or something.
This goes down DEEEP. Okaaay!
It's awfully terrifying in here...
*creature squeals loudly in the distance*
Well, alright then.
*creature bwongs*
That's... weird, is that the Sea Treader? I hope so!
"Detecting a titanium mass somewhere in this area. Unable to confirm whether it originated in THE AURORA!"
Oh! Are we talking about- Are we talking about the other base?
Oh, I think we're talking about the other base here.
Is the other base down here?
I mean, it WOULD be, the weirdos. They always do like to settle in the weirdest places.
So somewhere in here...
... there's a base. Oh and there's a Thermal Vent. Oh that's awfully handy!
Goddammit, why didn't I build my base down here?
Oh because my Seamoth can't get down this far?! Well FUCK ME then!
There's a Titanium Mass somewhere in here...
Me need some titanium me guessy.
Degasi! The Degasi, that's what it was, the Degasi.
*creature whistles*
Oh, my god! What the fuck is THAT?
Hehhh....
HEHhhhh...
Ayy! Ayyy! AYYyy! Okay! Alright! Okay!
Just gonna get da fuck outta HERE! Holy shit. HOly shit!
Ok. I'm just gonna go farther down, don't mind me.
Going down, baby- What the fuck are y- ? Oh, that's a Warper.
Oh, that is a Warper.
Oh, I shouldn't be here.
OH, THIS IS BAAAD!
Egh!
Oh god, why am I going farther down? This is bad, I'm gonna lose my god damn PRAWN!
*creature squeals*
Fuck.
Okay.
Do I go farther?
*Warper teleports*
Oh, that's not good...
That's not- that's, that's- Whatever that was, that's not good...
Oh, I'm- Oh my god that is terri- What is that? OH MY GOD!
*creature makes warbling clicking noises*
Ahhh! I hate this, I GOTTA GO!
Yeeeeeeeeeee! Oh yeee oh yee yo yay yee yo!
I didn't want to go down this way, but I didn't have a choice! I was being pressed in!
*creature screech*
From all sides!
Warpers and whatever the fuck that other thing was! Jesus, where is this leading?!
Oh jeez, I found the way down...
Oh, I'm not happy about it. Not HAPPY about it!
Oh not happy about this!
Oh NOT happy about this!
WHAT the FUCK is THIS?!
*low rumble*
What the FUCK?! Is this the Lost River?!
*ambience stops*
Ok music, yeah, you just cut out, you don't need to keep playing, yeah. I think-.
I'm pretty sure this might be the Lost River. Didn't mean to find THIS!
Oh boy oh boy oh boy, alright. Oh god, I don't wanna go down yet.
Am I ready? The problem is, I'm not ready to go down, I have no FOOD! Oh god, what is that?
Is that a tail of something or is that a- Is that just a "loading" thing?
I hate to be "that guy," but I'm not READY to go down there! I'm just not, if I go down there, I'm gonna die and I'm gonna lose my PRAWN suit!
I'm- LITERALLY, I'm Low Health, Low Food, Low WATER!
I'm just not ready.
Oh if I go down there, I'll die. I have to be smart about this, I have to find out where- how to get out of here, and where the fuck does THIS lead? What is THIS SHIT?!
WHAT IS THIS?!
Is this ANYTHING? No, it's nothing. It's like a goof. It's a goof. Yeah it's- It's just a fucking goof!
Oh boy, I gotta get out of here.
I hate to be "that guy" but I'm just- I'M NOT READY! I'LL DIEE!
There's no FOOD down there! There's no WATER...that's drinkable.
Aye yai yai yai yai yai yai yai!
Ok, so as I make my cowardly return back to my base, I was looking for Titanium and I did not find it.
I found death! A lot of that! Excess amounts of death and horror.
I am gonna read the comments that I was gonna put on a locker, but I ran out of titanium to make those.
I will put them on a locker, it's just I won't be able to do it today. Once I get the titanium- Ehhhyeye!
Oh god, I gotta get out of here alive. Ok, so, pretty much EVERYONE in the comments section said
that the Ghost Leviathan IS a THING! The Ghost Leviathan is actually going to be a thing!
Ahhh!!! What the FUCK is THAT?! Ok, bad! Bad! Bad!
So, what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna build a locker and put EVERYONE on it! Literally the word "Everyone," so all of you will be on the locker.
OH GOD NO! NO! FUCK YOU! OH FUCK! WHERE AM I?! HOW COULD YOU?!
Oh god, fuck you, fuck you dude, fuck you dude! Fuck you dude! Oh no, where's my- where is it? Where is it? There it is.
Oh my god, don't do that! I'm low on HEALTH!
Oh my god, getting out of here. Oh fuck. Ok, next up, "ShawnMarks35", who suggested I don't get the water purifier until I get steady source of power! Ohh god...
Euhhhhh! I got turned around, I didn't mean to go this way, I was trying to go a different way.
Oh fucking fuck. Where's my goddamn base? It's up there, okay. Just gotta go over there, just gotta make it, gotta make it, gotta make it. Okay.
So, I won't do that, I'll take my time with that, and then "PassTheWord35" said
"When you completed your moon pool powers and problem situation, invest in reinforcements"
HEYYY! FUCKING! FUCK YOU!!! Ehh! NooooooOOOOOOO!!!! NOOOOO!!!
AHH! FUCK OFF!!! Oh, fuck this! It's infested!
Oh GOD! There's so many of them! Oh I'm in the MIDDLE of the DEATH! Oh god, fuck off fuck off fuck off!
Ehuhhhewww!
Ahhahahh! I hate this, I hate this GODDAMN GO!!!
Fucking GO!!!
I'm gonna sidestep out of here. GET THE FUCK UP THERE!
Is that Titanium? I think that might be Titanium!
Guys, I think I found some! Guys! Good news! What was that?
Fucking where'd it go? Oh, no- LEAD?! Fucking fuck off!
Ok, what is that? Is that a wreck? Oh it is!
Is there a wreckage down here?
Woah, I didn't know that! Holy shit. Let me see what THIS is.
Scanner room?
Oh, hell yeah. I'll take that. Fuck, yeah.
Karen: Emergency. Severe dehydration detected.
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know.
I'm gonna grab a couple of these.
Well, shit. Killed that.
It's dead. It's very dead.
That's a dead one. Okay,
Dead bladderfish? Ugh...
Okay, so I gotta find...
I gotta do this quickly because I'm gonna get this
because I don't know--I'm not sure I'm gonna find this again.
I'll go in this one when I come back to it.
I thought I scanned this.
"Alien containment fragment"?
"Alien containment fragment"??
The fuck???
...the fuck is that?
I don't wanna contain ailmens (aliens), I-I-I wanna
KILL em all
Geez, I don't wanna contain 'em...
Okay, so the unfortunate thing is I think I have to go in there to get the rest of the pieces
unless there's some pieces down in this trench here...
which it looks like there is, I don't know what it's to, but either way it's gonna get me what I need.
"Scanner room" Okay. So I'm gonna go back in there
when I find the scan--cause I'll find it again
I should be able to find it again but I gotta get back
because I'm about to die of thirst, if I die I'm--this is all for nothing.
I gotta get back in there, like immediately.
Oh, why did I cut this so close?
I don't know
'cause I'm an IDIOT, THAT'S why.
Oh i have fucked--I have fucked myself over haven't I?
Ohhh I'm cutting, godamm this web--this episode is just
fucking nuts
okay and dododo <CAUTION: BLOOD NUTRIENT LEVELS DECREASING> dodododo dah dah DAHHH--
AAAAAAAYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYAYYYYYYYY
Holy fuck.
NO, you're not the one I need! Oh jeez...
please go faster, ohh god
come on (x4)
get the water in you (x3)
Did I have water on me?
I have no idea
Get the foooood..
Not the BLADDER fish!
Goddamnit that's not what i wanted to do.
Whatever it doesn't matter
Ok.
Good (x5)
YAAAS!
OK.
Good.
God.
This..
Holy fucking shit,
this entire episode.
Man this's been nutz
This has been a bonkers,
b0nkerz episode.
Kay, alright... I need titanium.
I need a LOT of titanium.
I need oodles... (CAUTION: Dehydration detected.)
God, I know... I'm... I'm in a bad way.
But
What I DO and DON'T have is everything.
And what I DO and DON'T want is... everything.
So, I'm... I'm in a I'm in a
spot of bother, here, but before I do that
I'm gonna put
I'm gonna put my Seamoth in the docking bay
Just to... cause I feel...
I feel like I've left... I've left my Seamoth out of here,
Just taking "Mr. Fister" for granted!
Uh, when, in fact, I want it to be the other way around. I love-
God d- WHY?! I JUST fucking- REALLY?! Are you gonna Mr. Fister?!
Is it because ya think I'm about ta neglect you?
Well no, that's not true, I just don't like you.
Alright, you're just not as good as BubbleButt, sorry to say.
If BubbleButt had a drill arm, I'd be a lot happier in my life.
<Welcome aboard captain>
Thanks Karen, you are a doll, aren't ya?
Ok, so that's gonna power THAT up. HaBOOSki!
Barely any power? You just sip power, baby.
You're so good, and I'm gonna color you UP BUBBLEBUTT!
Wup, no, hang on, wait, gotta see what we're doin' here.
Oo! No, what if we make it a Bumble Bee?
OH! WHAT IF WE MAKE IT A BUMBLE BEE?!!!
OOOOO!! AWh that's so NICE! Oh that's lovely! Ohh!
Oh! I'm gonna call you "BumbleButt"
OHH!
Oh it's BUMBLE BUTT!
Oh he's so CUTE! Ugh, ugly on the inside, but
OHO! So CUTE!
Oh BumbleButt I love you! Oh that's so good!
Ok, so what can I do? Probably nothing.
That IS the "Seamoth Perimiter Defense System"
which would be awfully nice!
"Polyaniline" I don't know how to make that.
Do I know how to make that? What is "Polyaniline?"
I have no idea what that is. I have NO idea.
So I've got a lot on my plate.
I've got a few more things before I want to end this episode, but I've got a lot on my plate.
But the first thing I need to do above all else is, AS USUAL,
GO GET FUCKIN' TI-TANIUM,
<Emergency: Severe Dehydration.>
and go take care of my goddamn dehydration bullshit.
Yeah, I know, I've got a plan. I've got something over here.
I can take care of this.
I also think I might be able to make a-
I might be able to make that Water Filtration System now.
It WOULD suck a lot of power out of what I've got, but...
At the same time, I MIGHT be able to afford a little bit of,
little bit of excess here, because it WOULD STOP-
OH! But it costs 2 Titanium! FUuUUuck!
Alright, so I gotta do that, ah fuck.
Ok, so EVERYTHING is-
*Seamoth thumps due to being deep*
[Tiny, high-pitched voice] Whaaaat the fuck was that?
What the fuck WAS that?
Did you hear that? That was the weirdest sound I've ever heard!
What the fuck WAS that? I don't know, and I don't wanna know, and I don't know anything.
I'm gonna save.
Euugh... Anyway, so what I need to do now is I need to go get Titanium and-
Oh my god, BumbleButt, I love you so much, you're so much better than the Prawn Suit!
In EVERY way, you are better than the Prawn Suit.
God, you are just so NIMBLE! You're so gloriously NIMBLE! OH, I love you!
Fuck, I love you baby!
Woah.
Heyo! That's- Have I seen that?
Have I seen this one? I don't know if I have, I think I would've recognized a piece like this just jutting straight up out of the middle of this sanded area.
I don't think I've ever seen this one before. What do you have?
Oh! "Alien Containment Fragment." Well you got the other piece of THAT that I needed, so that's good I- I think.
At least I'll get some Titanium out of THIS ONE, but maybe I can get some answers out of this one too.
I mean, eventually I'll need some water.
"Damage to plant life on the sea floor suggests this may be the migration path of huge bottom-dwelling lifeform."
*haunting choir voices*
Ahhh...
*voices intensify*
<Caution: Mild Dehydration Detected: Liquid Intake Recommended>
*voices stop*
Well okay, that was- That was disturbingly loud, and I'm not sure why that happened, but I'm gonna go in here.
Just kinda, you know, explore a bit. Ooo...
Well this looks dablaged.
Heavily dablaged. I'm just gonna get the Titanium out of these Alien Containment Framgents because-
*suction noise*
Woah, what the fuck was that?
What the fuck was THAT? Ok, weird...
But ok. "Nuclear-" YESS!!! YES!!! YES!! YES! YES!!!
YES! YES!!! YAAAS!!! YAAAAAAAS!!!
Oh that's good, oh, that is good, okay I need to unweld THIS.
Don't know if I have time for this, gonna get a little bit. C'mon, cut! Cut cut cut cut!
Cuuut!
<Caution: 30 Seconds Of Oxygen Remaining>
Cut! (x13)
Ok, good, half-done job there, but YES, "Nuclear Reactor" means SO much!
"Nuclear Reactor" means ALL of my power problems are GONE!
It takes a lot to build a Nuclear Reactor, THAT I know from the last time that I tried to build one, I had to cheat to do it.
And even through CHEATING, I had to like-
"It was so hard, I had to press so many buttons on the console, it was SOOOO difficult."
But that should be good, and THAT should do me SO well in the future! YES! YEAAS!
Oh shit, what the fuck? "Prawn Suit Propul-" OH MY GOD! This- This particular wreck is AWESOME!
Also I'm hearing VERY disturbing sounds, and I have bad feelings about that.
Oh, that's AWESOME! The Propulsion Arm would be CRAZY! Oh hell yeah!
This particular wreck is the best wreck that I've ever found.
But I just need one more Nuclear Reactor piece.
<Caution: 30 Seconds Of Oxygen Remaining>
Where the fuck is it? It's gotta be in here right? Fuck OH, running out of oxygen, like right now.
Ok, so- but there's gotta be...
<Emergency: 10 Seconds...>
There's gotta be another piece around here.
If it's not in there, there might be another entrance somewhere where it could be.
*high creature snarl*
Woah, what the fuck?
I'm hear- HEY!
FUCKING GOD DAMN IT! FUCK OFFFF!!! AGHH!
N-n-n-n-n! I'm outta here baby! I'm out! I'm out! I'm ouut! I'm outie! FUCK OFF!
Fuck off, what are you doin'? Where'd he go? Oh he teleported! I'm gonna assume he's teleporting TO ME!
Fucking fuck OFF with you! You piece of shit.
<Emergency: Severe Dehydration Detected>
God damn it, I don't wanna leave without the Nuclear Reactor Fragment!
Fuck THAT guy.
FUCK that guy. Jesus, ok, so I thought I saw another entrance in here.
But I just- Ah fuck, I can't take many more of those HITS! Gonna die. Jesus Christ. Why is he- He's like following me around!
Where did he go?
Ohh fuck, there he go! Nonono no, no you stay away, stay away.
Ok, so maybe there was another entrance up top. Nothing, aw fuck. I gotta go get water.
Where IS this place in relation to everything? This is WAY off the beaten path!
This is like WAY way way off the beaten path.
Goddammit, and the only entrance was over there, wasn't it?
God, there's just one more piece that I need. Fuck, he just pops in and out there.
I'm gonna go for it, I'm gonna go for it.
Ehh, slide in. Slide in to those DM's- Oh fuck, where am I?
Oh god, I slid too hard, slid to hard into the DM's
(Dank Memes)
Oh no. Oh no... Oh no... Ohh no!
OH NO! NOOOOOO! NOOO!!!! NAAAAAOO!
BumbleButt! HELP! Go get help boy! BUMBLEBUTT! GO GET HELP!
Bumblebutt! Bumblebutt! Bumblebutt? Bum- bumble- Don't let me die this way! BumbleButt. Do you hear me, BumbleButt?
Do you hear me? Bumbly Butt? Bumble butt? BUMBLE BUTT? Bum- BumbleButt... Oh fuck I'm dead...
Well, all I can hope is that the Warper will warp me out of here to safety! WARPER! HELP!
HELP ME!
<Caution: 30 Sec...>
Aw fuck.
God damn it, god damn it, GOD damn it. Oh, it's RIGHT THERE! LET ME OUT!
LET ME OUT! LET ME OUT!!! EAHH!! HOAAHHHo fucking...
*sobs* goddammit
Nooo! No my OH nOoooooo..
Ohhhh noooo! I'm in the-...
Ohh noooo! DAWH! FUCK MAN!
At least I know where that WRECK is now!
Ohh NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!
[calmly] Okay.
That's gonna do it for this episode. This episode has been a NIGHTMARE, but a...
progress-making nightmare! So...
I found the pieces to the Nuclear Reactor, I KNOW where the wreck is.
There's a Warper that's on my ass, but I think I can make it okay.
So thank you everybody so much for watching, I PROMISE I'm gonna make those GOD DAMN LOCKERS!
<Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan plays>
But soon. So thanks again, and as always, I will see YOU in the NEXT VIDEO, BUH BYE!
<Music intensifies>
<Music slides out>
<Music ends>